Gin no kun
I'll do it myself I
was there
I can really do it myself so it's okay
Umm yeah What are you doing alias Good morning
Shiraki Wait wait wait You
're going to college soon
So let's get ready for it
Soon  It's been more than two months since I left in September,
but before that, it seems I have to make a uniform, so I'll start
dancing
again.
I was thinking of doing it,
but
it would be quicker to leave it to my main job
.
You've grown up,
eh
, when you first came here, you were about this
size, right
?
I never thought I'd wear a uniform again Come to think of it, I
never heard about school from you I
don't have many memories that I would enjoy talking about, and
I'm still a little scared, but I'm wearing
this uniform  I look forward to wearing it